and speaking of former president trump
he is facing multiple investigations
including some that could result in
criminal charges they include probes
into the january 6 riot as well as the
investigation into those classified
documents found at mar-a-lago it's a lot
to keep track of but robert costa is
doing so for us from washington bob good
morning let's start with the mar-a-lago
situation there was a hearing yesterday
on how to handle the material found
there and marked as classified what
stood out to you
good morning johnny good to be with you
yesterday inside that courtroom in west
palm beach there wasn't a difference of
opinion there was a stark divide on one
side the trump lawyers compared this
probe of his possession of highly
sensitive records to a dispute over an
overdue library book and they argued
that a special master was needed to sift
through things independently meanwhile
the justice department those officials
argued forcefully that this
investigation is ongoing and very
serious in dealing with top secret
matters related to intelligence and
national security so there was a real
gulf in how they see this case legally
and how they see the stakes now they
just await the judge's ruling
as do all of us bob there are a number
of other investigations that are also
moving forward all tied to the former
president take a few take us through a
few of those other ones if you could
sure tony let's start with the house
select committee investigating the
january 6 attack it's now asking former
house speaker newt gingrich to sit for a
voluntary interview and when i reached
out to him last night gingrich was
surprised by this news and said it was
actually the first time he was hearing
about it the committee wants to talk to
him about trump's attempt to overturn
the 2020 election and it believes
gingrich played a role in that over the
phone gingrich called the committee
partisan and did not a commit to
appearing in any way saying quote he
would follow the advice of counsel
elsewhere in washington a federal grand
jury is reportedly expected to question
former white house counsel pat cipolloni
today regarding what he knows about what
happened inside the west wing before and
after the attack the justice department
is casting a wide net as it puts
together a possible conspiracy case
against republicans who coordinated to
block the certification of biden's
victory and finally a federal judge is
ordering senator lindsey graham to
testify before a grand jury down in
georgia though graham is still likely to
appeal that order they're looking at
whether trump and his allies pressured
officials in georgia to overturn the
state's election results and legal
experts believe this grand jury could be
working toward recommending possible
conspiracy charges and the district
attorney there fannie willis she has
been unrelenting in trying to get
crucial figures to testify tony
well as we said at the top there is a
lot going on in that uh bob thank you
for staying on top of it for us we
appreciate it